keanu reeves in the marvel cinematic
universe it could happen and some people
are refusing to give up a ghost keanu
reeves is easily one of the most
recognizable action movie stars alive
today and for good reason the john wick
movies have enjoyed monumental success
for being ultra violent ultra
entertaining thriller films overall all
three films have grossed 573 million
dollars worldwide and a fourth film is
on the way
you want a war
or do you want to just
give me a gun
more recently reeves starred in the
long-awaited fourth entry in the matrix
franchise the matrix resurrections
through all this fans have been
wondering when reeves would become
involved in the marvel cinematic
universe after all it wouldn't be his
first time stepping into a comic book
property it could previously be seen in
the titular role in 2005's constantine
based on the dc comics property reeves
has confirmed that he's met with marvel
studios president kevin feige but so far
they've been unable to come up the way
to bring the actor into the fold of
course where there's a will there's a
way naturally viewers have bided their
time by fan casting him in many roles
and one of the more popular dreamcasts
for reeves is that of ghostwriter
luckily for those fans some crafty
digital artists have imagined what
reeves could potentially look like in
the role late last year artist missouri
au posted some fan art of keanu reeves
with half of his face engulfed in flame
and showcasing the trademark ghost rider
skull from the leather jacket it seems
clear that this particular piece of art
is meant to portray reeves as the johnny
blaze incarnation of the character based
on the art alone the casting of reeves
seems almost like a no-brainer for a
ghost rider do-over especially following
the poor reception of the nicholas cage
ghost rider films
that's right
still there's no guarantee that reeves
will ever step into that role especially
given his busy schedule with the john
wick movies and whatever else he has in
the pipeline furthermore the walking
dead star norman reedus has shown a lot
of interest in the role as of late
prompting rumors that the part may
already be his of course missouri made a
mock-up of what that might look like too
either way it would be exciting for the
mcu to continue pushing in a darker
direction with ghost rider if the
upcoming release of the moon knight
series is any indication marvel seems
more willing to take things closer to
the edge alas mcu fans hoping for
concrete news regarding the future of
the ghost rider character will have to
continue to be patient congratulations
chancellors just went from none to swim
given his massive popularity it should
come as no surprise that fans will take
any excuse to have more keanu reeves in
their lives even if it doesn't work out
with ghost rider there are thousands of
characters across the pages of marvel
comics and surely there's a part out
there for reeves he may be nearly 60 but
he still has the star power to put butts
in the seats as such numerous artists
have envisioned what the actor could
look like is a variety of characters who
have still yet to appear in the mcu one
instagram artist that goes by the handle
dinesh 95 offered a glimpse of what he
would look like as neymar the submariner
there has been intense speculation that
namor could make an appearance in black
panther 2 but those have yet to be
confirmed it would undoubtedly be
challenging to hide reeves casting if
that's the case so perhaps it's possible
namor will make his debut in a later mcu
project the same account also posted
some artwork of reeves as a character we
know he won't appear as years ago dinesh
offered a portrait of reeves as adam
warlock we now know that that character
will appear in guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 as played by will poulter reeves
certainly would have been an excellent
pick for that part but it wasn't meant
to be that's not even getting into all
of the iconic characters reeves could
theoretically play one day like silver
surfer wonder man or nova an actor of
his talents could portray virtually
anyone and fans would be utterly
delighted then again reeves is a busy
man these days so perhaps a
multi-picture contract with marvel would
be too difficult to pull off still
there's nothing wrong with a little hope
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]